oui et donc thierry ardisson qui a fait
plein de révélations dans cette
interview sur le dans le fun poste et le
journaliste notamment garés à souligner
a posé une question sur vous et on le
connaît très grande gueule très
provocateur plutôt friands de bons mots
pour le buzz
il lui a dit donc vous cyril hanouna
s'est imposée comme la tête d'affiche de
ses 8 est-ce que la place de numéro 2 ça
vous gêne pas donc une question quand
même assez violente
il a répondu très gentiment vous coûte
que no more situera il faut lire entre
les lignes c'est 13 ans la période est
la colonne vertébrale de la chaîne il
connaît que c'est une très belle colonie
voilà pense qu'il est phénoménal
incroyable
ouais ah non il parle pas de moi là si
moi je fais par des tiges pendant deux
jours lui il arrive sur lui ai dit que
c'était un lander voilà que je souhaite
en pro leur pognon il dit vous avez le
pognon libyen montrent que lui que lui a
pas ôté but vous avez vous venez du bas
excusez moi aurons avril
excusez moi mais je vous trouve pour une
fois très naïf bon alors c'est voir
grande humanité qui voit mais
franchement la ville à des fouilles la
donnée ni tableau extrêmement politique
coordonnée entre les lignes
imed était là tout le monde voilà il
fait pression sur la chaîne en disant
ces deux émissions avec jeremstar ou
rien moi je veux bien il se place en
homme fort quand on fait des ultimatums
comme ça en général je vais vous dire on
les perd voilà lés malte alors c'est lui
laverai jamais hebbadj est très bien
pris on est mal apparemment on n'a pas
la même lecture
non le voile ya une chose qui m'a
interpellé c'est lorsqu'il a dit que et
c'est certainement vrai mais que lui
thierry ardisson et pète sur n'importe
quelle chaîne entre les lignes il a donc
sa personnalité fait nommer soeur est-ce
que c'est avec l'accord il avait rien
dit prêt à partir non c'est mon scénario
hélas il amène ses téléspectateurs et
clients total